going back to it all these people that
moved to florida they're very happy i'd
love to see a few interviews about
people that moved to florida that are
miserable today i do i speak to people
all the time and they say they made a
mistake moving here i'd love to see that
what i have been hearing i'd love to
interview them yeah i have to
thirty-something
that's a deal that's a real thing but
that's that's called supply and demand
you're in business you should know that
that's called capitalism that's supply
and demand but if you're one of the lord
you need to address your consensus
on the msnbc hit show that they did on
desantis which nikki was on they
interviewed a guy husband and wife they
said we came and we're paying thousand
dollars rent for a year and a half ago
you remember this and he said and they
increased my rent by 30
and it says so how did you handle that
he says well the the landlord told me
you can go elsewhere but that's the mark
you're right and he's like i went
everywhere else it was more than 30 so i
had to pay the 1300 bucks that's called
capitalism but you called it a rate hike
but but you called
let me finish this then you can push
back i mean let's uh change the topics
to people that live here you have a
point we'll get to that here in a minute
all i'm asking for is the people that
moved here i don't know anybody who's
unhappy to move here which means just
like a lot of immigrants who come to
america who love america and americans
[ __ ] about america they don't know what
it is to live in a different place so
you lived in texas and you lived here
you've not lived in california you've
not lived in new york and she's not
lived in new york and california you
guys don't know what it was to live with
these places that's why people are
leaving so as much as we want to say wow
this well this well that totally get it
we're coming to you because all your
stuff you're bitching about we are very
happy about we are very happy about the
stuff that this guy has done so that's
all i'm saying with the argument so if
people you're meeting who have moved you
who are not happy tell me why they say
they're not happy you know what they're
coming down here and people have come
here and i and i speak to people okay
all day long all walks of life and when
i hear they'd say they come down here
they've moved down here and they didn't
realize how bad the culture wars were
that they have a kid who potentially is
a member of the lgbtq no one's saying
that i haven't heard that no one's
saying that well i don't know who you're
all talking to we have kids we have kids
i i get it we are around people with
kids and i and i'm around people with
kids all day long and we have like i
have four kids like i know what happens
in schools i'm i'm the guy that's
talking to these people with other
parents i haven't heard anybody saying
oh they're not letting my kid choose
what they want to be i'm saying that
that they because of some of these
policies which ones which policies the
one with lgbt which is disney good
please continue that's kind of where
you're going with so and that was just
one example yeah but what i'm hearing
across the board is we didn't realize
how contentious this was and how much
tension there is on the ground you can't
talk to your neighbors that now we're
dealing with things that are inside the
education can you please interview these
guys and put a video out absolutely can
you please interview these guys and and
allow us as well to speak to them i'll
be happy i'm telling you i talk to
people all the time that have moved we
do too though but we do as well okay but
but here's but here's what i'm gonna
push back on please do so okay you're
you're attacking me on i'm not attacking
you what i'm saying is what i'm saying
is i'm saying your governor's done a
good job on why so many are moving you
can go to the areas that have he's not
done a good job fine you can bring those
up but in this area when it comes on to
stuff that she talked about she made a
very good point when it comes on to
families with kids no taxes leaving me
be who i am let me be free the things
that matter to us that has to do with
fundamentals that america offers this
has been the best state the last two
years there's not been a better state
than this state the last two years oh
and obviously i disagree and that's and
that's fine that's why you're here to
push yourself you have to say what's a
better state than florida these days
because let me just weigh in i ask i
have tons of friends that moved here
from new york specifically
the i i want them to leave they're my
friends i'm like please guys go back to
new york they're like we're not we're
not leaving
like almost like jordan bell for like
we're not leaving
all of them nikki i want them to leave i
i was paying rent this much it
skyrocketed that's i'll be okay i've got
some money in the bank but there's a lot
of friends out there that do not and as
much as you're saying no there's a lot
of people unhappy i talk to these people
my job is to talk to people for a living
they're all staying and i want them to
leave and they're my friends so you
can't say that you're running into a lot
of people who are unhappy moving here
they wouldn't move here if they were
unhappy here well a lot of them don't
understand what some of the culture
issues when they get to the ground and
especially if they're a minority
community a lot more culture issues in
l.a or new york
florida's been purple forever i don't
fight with anybody if i go to california
i'm fighting with the republican i'm
even fighting with democrats same thing
in brooklyn new york there's not that
much fighting here in florida and that's
why i love florida i i haven't debated
this much people since i've been around
more people from la new york florida i
got cuban friends haitian friends this
person that person jewish friends it's
more of a melting pot than all these
other states you know i'm wondering if
the issue is like anywhere you move it's
not going to be perfect for you there's
going to be something about it the
energy the vibe you're talking about
cultural issues you're going to find
something that doesn't work for you but
the challenge is is that if you compare
like a new york to a florida or a
lawsuit i mean there are places these
cities are sinking around the country
many of them are sinking what people are
saying to themselves is
maybe florida's not perfect but on these
issues that really matter like you're
not talking about anything if you can't
feed your family
that comes number one there are priority
issues for people if you can't put gas
in your tank
it doesn't matter you can't get where
you need to go you can't worry about all
of this other stuff that's secondary so
on those priority issues people by and
large and i say this as somebody who
wasn't like i don't love the climate in
florida that would not have been my
first choice i would have been waiting
for the summer there
all right
no joke this would not have been my
first choice i i always wanted to move
to los angeles and i'm deeply
heartbroken that i can't move there
because it's being buried right now and
i don't feel safe raising my
two-year-old there but i think the issue
is like there are core issues that
people feel
florida's doing those right and and and
if they and if florida wasn't doing
those right you would see a mass exodus
of people from florida to new york city
to los angeles you know if if the
cultural issues on the ground in florida
were so horrible and people who had you
know if lgbtq whatever it is whatever
your issue is if that was the priority
issue you would see those numbers moving
the other way they're not well
but here's the problem you know because
at the end of the day and which is why i
don't talk about culture wars on a
normal basis i talk about economics
economics 101 that's why people vote but
the people that are suffering here in
our state and i'm glad that you can
afford a 30 of 40 or 60 increase in your
rent but the people that i talk to every
day
i had a call yesterday with somebody
going i'm getting evicted i can't afford
an extra seven years that's what i'm
saying is the majority of my friends are
struggling like that i'm not i'm not
disagreeing with you they're struggling
and there's been no conversations about
how to fix it and so people are sitting
here and i am talking to people saying
i'm gonna have no choice but to leave
this day because i can't afford to live
here anymore but in miami the number one
city in the state that's not on desantis
isn't that on mayor suarez i mean what
do you have to say about what he's done
whole other thing
i i think it goes back to the same
fundamental issue okay look and this is
why i'm running for governor
is is to make sure that there are
differences of opinions obviously you
hear that in this room it's great and
that's fantastic but what has happened
in our state is that those differences
of opinions and those different
conversations don't see the light of day
because they're shut down
desantis does not
how many cabinet meetings has he
cancelled on me because he refuses to
listen to what i have to say how many
times has he not listened to the people
in the room that he's yelled at at
reports other states
other states like like this doesn't
happen in other states i'm just i i am
talking about florida okay my my my
friends so listen i think you guys you
gotta you something happen between the
two of you guys that you guys got you
know that's that's you guys got to go
have some lunch one day so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]